what big ideas have you changed your
mind on in the last few years
i mean there's a lot on kind of a life
level
uh there's a couple obviously in the
business level
um i think on a more practical basis
i've just stopped believing in
macroeconomics
great i i studied i studied economics
and school and computer science and know
the time when i thought i was going to
go be a a phd in economics and all that
but the further i get the more
microeconomics the combination of voodoo
complex systems of politics
and you can find macroeconomists to take
every side of every argument so i think
that discipline because it doesn't make
falsifiable predictions which is the
hallmark of science because it doesn't
make falsifiable predictions just become
corrupted
because you you never have the counter
example on the economy you never you can
never take the us economy and run two
different experiments at the same time
and because there's so much data people
kind of cherry pick for whatever
political narrative they're trying to
push
so to the extent that people spend all
their time watching the macro economy or
uh you know the fed forecasts or uh you
know which way the uh
stocks are going to go the next year is
going to be a good year or a bad year
that's all junk it's no better than
astrology
in fact it's probably even worse because
it's less entertaining it's just more
stress-inducing
so i i just think of macroeconomics not
a junk science with all apologies to
macroeconomist that said microeconomics
and game theory are fundamental
i don't think you can be successful in
business or even navigating through most
of our modern capital society without an
extremely good understanding of supply
and demand and
labor versus capital and
game theory and um uh tit-for-tat and
those kinds of things um so that that
macroeconomics is a religion that i gave
up but there are many others i mean i've
changed my mind on death on the nature
of life on the purpose of life on uh on
marriage you know i was originally not
someone who wanted to be married and
have kids um so there have been a lot of
fundamental changes but the most
practical one is i gave up macro and i
embraced micro and i would say that's
just not true in macroeconomics that's
true in everything i don't believe in
macro environmentalism i believe in
micro environmentalism i don't believe
in macro charity i believe in micro
charity um i don't believe in macro
improving the world like there's a lot
of people out there who get really fired
up about going to change the world i'm
going gonna change this person would
change the way people think i think
about micro it's like change yourself
then maybe change your family and your
neighbor before you get into abstract
concepts about i'm gonna change the
world i was curious how much you think
about macro events when you're investing
or if it's
really focused company specific and
that's something that's sort of like
really at the end
where that comes up in your process
i think investing is difficult enough if
you're just trying to understand a
business and how it works
i think when you start overlaying and
trying to make assumptions okay here's
what i think will happen to interest
rates or unemployment or recession in
this year or that year
all of those things most people are
wrong about everything i thought that
would happen with covet
in march 2020 turned out to be wrong
i mean i would have never guessed that
now we'd be sitting at all-time highs
on the stock market after you know more
than half a million people died in the
u.s and we had all these lockdowns and
stores and everything shut down and
businesses people working remote i also
wouldn't have thought that
remote work would have led to a more
productive workforce not a less
productive workforce it's all
counter-intuitive
and so i think that the best thing to do
is
not to give too much weight
and not to think too much about the
macro
because it's a lot harder and it may not
have an effect in the end at all
[Music]
[Music]
you